With "Spider-Man: No Way Home,"
the MCU is officially broken.
"I am truly sorry for whatever I — and
everything I have ever done to you."
Before we go any further, just
know there’s major spoilers
ahead - not just for the end credit scene.
Thanks to Peter Parker and Doctor Strange,
the multiverse splits wide open in the
third Tom Holland "Spider-Man" movie.
In a lot of ways, this movie reaches back
to the prior Sony "Spider-Man" movies,
bringing in all kinds of characters and callbacks
that had nothing to do with the MCU – until now.
But the biggest change for the Marvel Cinematic
Universe happens in the movie's post-credits
scene, which acknowledges, for the first
time ever, an ongoing superhero series
set outside the MCU.
"That guy, right?"
"Yep."
The first "Spider-Man: No
Way Home" post-credits scene picks up around the
same time the events in New York come to a close,
with Doctor Strange casting a new spell to make
everyone forget Peter Parker again, no matter who
they are and or what universe they're from.
The scene starts with Tom Hardy's Eddie Brock
sitting at a tropical bar and talking to a
bartender about the events of the MCU so far.
This moment picks up from the post-credits
scene of "Venom: Let There Be Carnage,"
which sees Eddie and the symbiote wake up
in a new universe — apparently the MCU.
He gets the general idea that Thanos used the
Infinity Stones to wipe out half of all life in
the universe for five years before the Avengers
manage to bring everyone back in "Endgame." But,
because Eddie knows a little about
aliens, he starts to dispute the idea
until Venom tells him he's drunk and starts to
force him to walk away from the conversation.
Before things can go any further, the
Lethal Protector is yanked out of the MCU
thanks to Doctor Strange's second spell.
It's surprising the film doesn't keep Venom
in the MCU. It would be a perfect opportunity for
Peter to go up against Eddie, but it does have
one drastic effect on this universe. When Eddie is
zapped from the bar, he accidentally leaves a part
of the symbiote behind. Uh-oh.
"Now dig on this."
The symbiote left behind in the MCU sets the
stage for Peter Parker to end up donning the
iconic black suit at some point in a future movie.
We already know Sony is supposedly planning a
brand new trilogy with Tom Holland reprising
his role as the young wall-crawling hero. We
also know Holland's Peter still lives in the MCU
at the end of "Spider-Man: No Way Home." However,
his circumstances are vastly different because
everyone has completely forgotten him thanks to
Doctor Strange's new spell. This allows Spidey
to go through almost a total reset in the MCU.
After Spider-Man first encounters the symbiote
in the Marvel Comics issue "Secret Wars #8,"
he quickly gets enchanted by the enhanced strength
and speed it gives him. Now, it's not unreasonable
to imagine that the same might happen to the
MCU's Spider-Man since he'll be operating
without most of his fancy nanotech and will not
have access to other Stark Industries resources.
As such, it'll be interesting to see how (or if)
the Symbiote Suit affects Peter – we know it can
do a number on the wearer's personality.
"You want forgiveness? Get religion."
This event could still set up a future
confrontation between Eddie and Peter
further down the line, too. In "Venom:
Let There Be Carnage," Venom starts to
tell Eddie that the Symbiote Collective
Mind knows plenty about other universes,
so it's not impossible they'll come looking for
the piece they left behind in the MCU. Obviously,
Sony and Marvel could choose to take things in a
completely different direction, but as of right
now, the future of this universe is wide-open.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about the
Marvel Cinematic Universe are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.